c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
perçue jean paul jean pierre et toute la
compagnie au paradis chico del ticino
les faits
[Musique]
m
paoli
e patton
lee roy tous avec
avec un jack roy est une icône
enfin
non je
creuser
les cages de guillotine
michaud
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est vrai j'en roissy à paris
[Musique]
si gentille intelligemment mais dommage
on met autour des gares
[Musique]
ça dit moi chef d'accord décoiffé jeu
là
là en bio des budgets tu vas rentrer
jours de mer
[Musique]